Well there is,
there is no doubt that the whole
discussion globally about how to deal
with the climate crisis is still,
uh,
for most people,
the most essential part.
And it's,
it would be very unfortunate unless we
find ways to deal seriously with the
climate crisis and to present it
because,
uh,
that,
eh,
unless that happens,
we certainly are not going to see
sustainable development as we look
ahead.
I think,
Eh,
basically when you look at all the
elements that,
that are on the table and in the
discussion even linked up to the climate
change discussion,
all the key issues linked to the
sustainable development concept itself
are part of that discussion.
So it's not as if something has been
completely lost as we focus on climate,
because in the whole area of adaptation,
uh,
of,
all the sectors that need to be involved
to deal with,
uh,
reducing the impact of on our climate,
we touched most issues which are
relevant in a sustainable development
context.
Well,
I think whether you look at the,
the,
the question of,
uh,
the way our democracies,
most countries are today.
Democracies,
although not all,
uh,
democracy means public participation.
And it means at the same time elected
representatives and a democratic
institutions that can help safeguard the
way that people live together and the
way we live in relationship with the
surrounding world and our environment.
So whether you look at it at national
level or at the global level,
there is this direct link between public
participation and engagement and the way
that leaders who have been elected,
uh,
or who are at least in any case,
responsible for the future of their
people,
how they can act together and,
uh,
have addition and,
and method of moving ahead in a
consistent and sustainable manner.
I think it's true to say that,
um,
a lot of politics and the positioning
and different,
uh,
national interests and perspectives have
entered into this global and very key
issue.
Uh,
this happens in many cases were
important issues are at stake.
So it's not something I'm only specific
for the climate issue.
But here you have major powers and you
have major sectors,
uh,
businesses,
which have been used to having a strong
influence,
uh,
in,
in many countries.
And they all are positioning themselves
and pushing for their own interests,
uh,
even short term.
So there is a challenge to people across
the world to look beyond this and the
challenge to leaders as we saw happening
in Copenhagen,
by the way,
that they have to put their heads
together and feel responsible as a team
across borders,
not just,
uh,
do,
politicking in their own national
framework.